so today is my first time trying sushi
I've never tried salmon I've never tried
shrimp seafood in general it's not
really my thing I'm really nervous right
now I feel like shaky I hope it takes
like ceviche I have no idea what this is
or this or that
Oh sticky rice I love sticky rice I
could do sticky rice all day I'm using
my hands abandoning the chopsticks
mm-hmm-hmm
is really gross I'm not I don't do slimy
things I like it Patroni glue it's like
I feel like I'm eating like muscle I
don't know what it is but it's good yeah
that was tuna I'll go for the salmon cuz
I like salmon when it's cooked I'm not
even gonna smell it cuz oh God
Oh mmm oh my god that was the grossest
one mm-hmm oh it's so slimy yeah not a
fan I don't understand why you wouldn't
cook your salmon like I just I want to
see some grill marks on this beef I mean
on the restroom I'm not gonna pick that
one for sure some ginger a little Bobby
no I guess that a lot I can't really
tell that's supposed to be a lot of
wasabi I don't know why I did that
just one really good ah
that's what's not that bad
that's hot yeah yeah I dig this one holy
spicy no no we take a break actually
went a lot better than I thought it
would
yeah I would eat ish again I guess if I
go out with my friends I'll have
something that I can order now besides
egg rolls it wasn't the most disgusting
thing I've ever eaten
actually I don't know I want to get the
first one I love the first one thanks
that's not really good